dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I here
a few years ago scientists a deep mind
published a learning algorithm that they
called deep reinforcement learning which
quickly took the world by storm this
technique is a combination of a neural
network that processes the visual data
that we see on the screen and a
reinforcement learner that comes up with
the gameplay related decisions which
proved to be able to reach superhuman
performance on computer games like Atari
breakout this paper not only sparked
quite a bit of mainstream media interest
but also provided fertile grounds for
new follow-up research works to emerge
for instance one of these follow-up
papers infused these agents with a very
human-like quality curiosity further
improving many aspects of the original
learning method however had a
disadvantage I kid you not it got
addicted to the TV and kept staring at
it forever this was perhaps a little too
human-like in any case you may rest
assured that this shortcoming has been
remedied since and every follow-up paper
recorded their scores on a set of Atari
games measuring and comparing is an
important part of research and is
absolutely necessary so we can compare
new learning methods more objectively
it's like recording your time for the
Olympics at the 100-meter dash in that
case it is quite easy to decide which
athlete is the best however this is not
so easy in a research in this paper
scientists a deep mind note that just
recording the scores doesn't give us
enough information anymore there's so
much more to reinforcement learning
algorithms than just scores so they
built a behavior suite that also
evaluates the seven core capabilities of
reinforcement learning algorithms among
these seven core capabilities the list
generalization which tells us how well
the agent is expected to do in
previously unseen environments how good
it is at credit assignment which is a
prominent problem in reinforcement
learning credit assignment is very
tricky to solve because for instance
when we play a strategy game we need to
make a long sequence of strategic
decisions and in the end if we lose an
hour later we have to figure out which
one of these many many decisions led to
our loss
measuring this as one of the core
capabilities was in my opinion a great
design decision here how well the
algorithm scales to larger problems also
gets a spot as one of these core
capabilities I hope this testing suite
will see widespread adoption in
reinforcement learning research and what
I am really looking forward to is seeing
these radar plots for newer algorithms
which will quickly reveal whether we
have a new method that takes a different
trade-off than previous methods or in
other words has the same area within the
polygon but with a different shape or in
the case of a real breakthrough the area
of these polygons will start to increase
luckily a few of these charts are
already available in the paper and they
give us so much information about these
methods I could stare at them all day
long and I cannot wait to see some newer
methods appear here now note that there
is a lot more to this paper if you have
a look at it in the video description
you will also find the experiments that
are part of this suite what makes a good
environment to test these agents in and
that they plan to form a committee of
prominent researchers to periodically
review it I love that part if you
enjoyed this video please consider
supporting us on patreon if you do we
can offer you early access to these
videos so you can watch them before
anyone else or you can also get your
name immortalized in the video
description just click the link in the
description if you wish to chip in
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time